Transcriptor: DD Chang
Revisor: Paula Motter
Me gustaría empezar lanzando una pregunta.
Una pregunta muy sencilla.
¿Alguno de vosotros conoce
aquel eslogan publicitario
que fue un éxito y triunfó en los años 90,
y que reflejaba de una manera
muy clara cómo era el mundo
en aquel momento de paso, de transición,
entre el siglo XX y el siglo XXI?
Me refiero a un eslogan corto,
de dos palabras,
que fueron elegidas como la marca europea
más valorada entonces:
"Connecting people".
Muchos lo recordaréis.
Es increíble cómo con solo dos palabras
se puede reflejar algo
que tiene que ver con un paso importante
en la evolución humana.
Porque lo que sucedió entonces
es que los seres humanos
rompimos el cordón umbilical
que nos ataba a la pared
en las comunicaciones de larga distancia
y que nos limitaba.
Hasta entonces, nos comunicábamos
solo en algunos momentos
y desde algunos lugares.
A partir de ahí, y gracias
a este pequeño aparato,
todas las personas pasamos
a estar comunicadas
en todo momento y en todo lugar.
El cambio es importante, es evolutivo.
Pero duró poco: ese eslogan
hoy está obsoleto ya.
Porque a esta tecnología
le sucedió la siguiente.
Y hubo un día en enero de 2007
cuando Steve Jobs nos anunció
un producto revolucionario
que lo cambiaría todo,
el que todos llevamos
en nuestros bolsillos : el "smartphone",
que realmente es un facilitador
de la vida digital,
sobre todo en el momento en el que
da lugar a un enorme universo de apps,
de aplicaciones, que nos facilitan la vida
y van cambiando el mundo.
¿Y cómo es este nuevo mundo
que está surgiendo?
A mí me gustaría distinguir o destacar
tres rasgos que definen
nuestro nuevo mundo.
El primero: es un mundo en cambio.
Cambio permanente, cambio acelerado,
cambio exponencial.
En segundo lugar, hemos entrado
en una nueva era: es la era digital,
en la que muchas de nuestras creencias,
valores y códigos de comportamiento,
se ven alterados.
Y en tercer lugar, es un mundo
hiperconectado como nunca en la historia.
Hoy tenemos un nivel de conectividad
total entre las personas
y se están empezando a conectar
las cosas, el Internet de las cosas,
que no sabemos
hasta dónde nos va a llevar.
Es interesante.
Y, a partir de ahí, dos cuestiones más
respecto a este nuevo mundo.
Primera: ¿Cuál es el motor
que impulsa este nuevo mundo?
Yo creo que hay pocas dudas:
el motor es la tecnología.
Siempre la tecnología ha sido
un impulsor del mundo,
desde la invención de la rueda,
la imprenta, la electricidad.
Pero en este momento,
lo está haciendo de una manera
más intensa, más sofisticada,
con un alcance mayor.
Y la siguiente cuestión: ¿Cuál es
el escenario de este nuevo mundo?
Sin duda alguna,
el escenario es la ciudad.
Las ciudades tienen hoy un protagonismo
como no lo han tenido nunca
en la historia de la humanidad.
Las ciudades están creciendo.
El porcentaje de población
que habita en ciudades
está creciendo en todo el mundo.
Cuando hablo de ciudades me refiero
a ciudades pequeñas, medianas, grandes,
en general.
Pero lo cierto es que
las ciudades están de moda.
En las ciudades están pasando cosas.
La ciudad es el lugar donde todo sucede.
Y el ser humano se ha convertido
en un ser urbano.
¿Y qué sucede cuando superponemos
estos dos conceptos,
tecnología y ciudad?
Pues lo que ocurre es que da lugar
a un enorme campo de actividad,
un enorme campo
de oportunidades y de desarrollo,
que muchas empresas han detectado
y están desarrollando soluciones
bajo la marca "Smart City".
¿Qué es "Smart City"?
La aplicación de
inteligencia artificial a las ciudades,
la aplicación de soluciones
basadas en la tecnología
al desarrollo de las ciudades.
Y está bien. Es un concepto positivo.
Pero posiblemente podemos ir
un paso más allá.
Porque hay una cosa que creo
que no debemos olvidar,
y es que las ciudades tienen alma,
no solo tecnología.
Una ciudad tiene alma.
¿Qué significa que una ciudad tiene alma?
A mí me gusta sintetizarlo en tres rasgos
que tienen que ver con
el pasado, presente y futuro.
Respecto al pasado,
una ciudad con alma es aquella
que es consciente de su identidad,
ha heredado una identidad
y la utiliza en el presente
para ponerla en valor.
Y vive, pervive
su identidad, la cuida.
Respecto al presente, es una ciudad
que pone el foco en las personas
para todos los proyectos,
desarrollo, planificación, etc.
Lo importante: las personas.
Y en tercer lugar, respecto al futuro,
son ciudades con proyecto,
ciudades que tienen una visión,
y que tienen luego las herramientas
para llevar esa visión a la acción.
Bien.
Pero volvamos a la idea inicial.
Estamos ya en un mundo en el que
las personas estamos conectadas.
Ahora estamos en proceso
de conectar las cosas,
y, dentro de las cosas,
toca también conectar
la "cosa" más grande,
más sofisticada y mas compleja
que el ser humano ha creado: la ciudad.
Por lo tanto, las ciudades también
se están conectando unas con otras,
y esto es algo que genera enormes
oportunidades y beneficios
para la población, para la sociedad,
para los que allí vivimos,
especialmente si nos referimos
a las ciudades de tamaño medio,
aquellas en las que vivimos
la mayor parte de nosotros.
Tamaño "medio" se considera a las ciudades
entre 50 000 habitantes y 1 millón.
Es decir, esas ciudades
obtienen muchas ventajas
del hecho de conectarse
con ciudades próximas
y trabajar en claves de cooperación.
Estas ideas las han desarrollado
con intensidad algunos pensadores.
Por ejemplo, recientemente Parag Khanna
ha publicado un libro
en el que desarrolla estos conceptos.
Se llama el concepto
de la "conectografía".
En mi caso, he dedicado
mi vida profesional
a trabajar sobre ciudades y territorios,
a contribuir a la transformación
de ciudades y de territorios.
Y en ese sentido, pues acumulo
ya una cierta experiencia.
En los últimos 25 años,
con los equipos de la fundación Metrópoli
hemos desarrollado planes y proyectos
que tienen que ver con estos conceptos.
Conceptos relacionados con redes
de ciudades, ciudades conectadas,
ciudades que se unen a otras
y se planifican conjuntamente
para de esa manera ser más fuertes, más
competitivos en el contexto internacional
y ofrecer más calidad de vida
a las personas que la habitan.
Hoy vamos a compartir otros ejemplos
que tienen que ver con esta forma
de entender las ciudades.
Ubicados a 8000 kilómetros
de distancia uno del otro,
en torno al océano Atlántico,
mirando a dos mares,
el Cantábrico y el Caribe;
en dos continentes, Europa y América;
en dos momentos históricos,
siglo XX y XXI;
pero en ambos casos con un rasgo en común:
proyectos que buscan
el desarrollo de la sociedad.
El primero de ellos se puso
en marcha en los años 90,
aquí, en Bilbao, en el País Vasco.
Yo nací cerca de aquí
y viví aquí mi infancia,
a pocos minutos de Bilbao.
Y recuerdo, como recordaréis
muchos de vosotros,
cómo era la vida en los años 80, 90.
Era una etapa difícil.
Había problemas, había declive económico,
violencia terrorista, todo tipo
de problemas ambientales,
degradación ambiental,
de la naturaleza, etc.,
y una sensación extendida de desánimo,
de preocupación hacia el futuro.
Esta imagen refleja este lugar
en el que estamos.
Y este lugar se transformó.
Donde se construían barcos,
hoy se construyen ideas,
hoy se construye talento,
hoy se construye interacción
entre las personas.
Y al igual que se transformó este lugar,
se transformaron otros,
en un esfuerzo colectivo
que en dos décadas cambió
la ciudad de Bilbao
y la llevó a otro plano, la llevó
a otra situación, afortunadamente.
El icono de la transformación
es el Museo Guggenheim,
que precisamente
acaba de cumplir 20 años.
Pero a mí me gustaría poner el énfasis
en algo que también
cumplió 20 años hace poco,
y es la Estrategia Territorial vasca.
A la vez que se inauguraba el museo,
se aprobaba esa estrategia
que está a día de hoy todavía vigente
y que ha contribuido a generar
un cambio en el territorio vasco,
un desarrollo,
una transformación positiva.
Una transformación positiva
basada en la definición
de un nuevo modelo territorial.
¿Por qué? Porque las ciudades
y los territorios se transforman.
Son entes vivos. Son entes
que tienen momentos en su vida:
momentos buenos, momentos
malos, momentos regulares.
Por lo tanto, este territorio
se ha transformado
a partir de la visión
de un modelo territorial,
al igual que lo ha hecho
la villa de Bilbao.
El País Vasco se concibe
en esa estrategia territorial
como un modelo policéntrico
en el que las tres ciudades capitales,
es decir tres ciudades medias
–Bilbao, Donostia-San Sebastián
y Vitoria-Gasteiz–
se articulan según criterios
de cooperación
y complementareidad entre ellas,
no competencia interna,
para así dar lugar a un ecosistema
de innovación y calidad de vida
que integra también
y favorece las ciudades menores,
los pueblos,
los espacios naturales,
los espacios productivos,
el litoral.
Y todo ello a partir
de un modelo de conectividad
basado en un sistema sólido
y robusto de infraestructuras
–carreteras, puertos, aeropuertos–
y de manera singular,
un sistema ferroviario,
que en su momento
se planteó como un sueño,
que hoy ya está en
una avanzada fase de construcción
y pronto será una realidad.
Este sistema de alta velocidad ferroviaria
va a permitir dos cosas.
Por una parte,
la conectividad de larga distancia
con Madrid o con París,
pero por otro lado muy importante,
la conectividad interna
de la ciudad región,
el metro de la ciudad región.
Las tres capitales se pondrán
a media hora de distancia una de la otra,
y eso es importante.
Cuando yo era niño, hace pocos años,
pues plantear un viaje
entre las capitales vascas
era preparar un viaje;
había que hacer la maleta.
Hoy la conectividad es fluida,
es ágil, es cotidiana.
Y dentro de poco va a ser
mucho más natural,
como moverse en metro
por una ciudad región.
Esto es importante: genera
desarrollo, genera progreso
y genera bienestar para la sociedad.
Bien.
A partir de aquí, volvemos al presente
y hacemos un viaje al Caribe.
Nos vamos a conocer el otro ejemplo
que os quería compartir,
que es el proyecto
"Diamante Caribe" en Colombia,
coliderado por el gobierno nacional,
los gobiernos de 10 provincias
y los 11 alcaldes
de las ciudades principales,
como Cartagena, Barranquilla,
Bucaramanga, Santa Marta, etc.,
y con un esfuerzo de innovación social
en el que dimos entrada a líderes
de distintos colectivos
de esas ciudades y territorios
para que manifestaran su opinión.
Este proyecto se desarrolló recientemente
sobre un territorio maravilloso
donde viven 14 millones de personas,
en el que hay enormes oportunidades,
biodiversidad, etc.,
pero también hay graves problemas.
Problemas que a veces tienen que ver
con la falta de desarrollo
y falta de colectividad.
El proyecto nació en el momento
en el que el gobierno
comenzaba a preparar los acuerdos
de paz con la guerrilla.
En consecuencia, ellos vieron que llevar
desarrollo a los territoriso más olvidados
es un prerrequisito para alcanzar
una paz estable y duradera.
Enseguida nos dimos cuenta
de que el acceso a ciertos lugares
era complicado
–carreteras sin asfaltar,
avionetas, canoas, etc.–
y llegamos a dos conclusiones
que son extrapolables
a otros lugares también.
Primero,
que las áreas de mayor desarrollo
son las áreas donde están las ciudades
y el ámbito directo
de la influencia urbana.
Esto es muy importante.
Y segundo, más dramático,
que las áreas de pobreza extrema
son aquellas áreas
donde anida la violencia
y aquellas son, precisamente,
las que tienen un déficit
de conectividad,
las que están mal conectadas
con las ciudades
y con el resto del territorio.
Conclusión: hay que atacar
ese tema de lleno. Es importante.
Por eso el proyecto propone
un centenar de acciones
dirigidas a mejorar,
fomentar el desarrollo de esas ciudades
y especialmente la conectividad
entre ellas y de los territorios olvidados
en beneficio del desarrollo social
de toda la población.
Y como no podía ser
de otra manera en este caso,
dada la época en la que
estamos viviendo, en este proyecto,
además de las cuatro infraestructuras
clásicas de conectividad,
–carreteras, ferrocarriles,
puertos y aeropuertos–
se aborda también una quinta,
que es la infraestructura
de conectividad digital,
las tecnologías digitales, la nube,
todo lo que ese mundo nos aporta,
realizando por primera vez,
una convergencia entre la planificación
física y la planificación digital
al servicio del desarrollo de la sociedad.
Y para terminar, me gustaría
lanzar una reflexión.
¿En qué nos afecta todo esto
de la conectividad a nuestra vida diaria?
Pues hay una cuestión clara.
Muchos estudios han demostrado
que la conexión social genera bienestar,
salud e incluso longevidad.
Eso nos lleva, llegando al campo
de las ciudades, a pensar
que más allá de las megalópolis
sin alma, de escala inhumana,
que a veces parecen
que están llamadas a liderar el mundo,
existe un enorme espacio de oportunidad
para las ciudades medias,
siempre que estén conectadas
formando redes,
y de esa manera sumen
sus activos unas con otras.
El territorio vasco ha hecho ese esfuerzo
en las dos últimas décadas
y ha logrado una transformación
positiva, modélica.
El Caribe colombiano esta lanzándose
ahora en este proceso
y también está aspirando a definir
un modelo territorial de progreso y futuro.
Pues a partir de ahí,
y volviendo a la idea inicial,
mi conclusión es muy clara.
Tenemos suerte
de estar viviendo este momento.
Como decíamos al principio,
hace 20 años el reto era conectarse
las personas, y ese reto se logró.
Hoy estamos en un mundo diferente
en el que se está construyendo
un mundo hiperconectado,
con una conectividad
que afecta a todas las cosas
y entre ellas también a las ciudades,
el lugar donde se produce
la vida en comunidad
y el encuentro entre las personas.
Por eso, es interesante y es inteligente
apreciar los valores
de las ciudades medias, conectadas,
–conectadas en red, conectadas entre si,
conectadas con el mundo–
para de esa manera aprovechar
y sacar todo el partido
a este mundo de nueva conectividad
que la sociedad actual nos aporta
y que se puede y se debe poner
al servicio de la calidad de vida
de las personas.
Muchas gracias.
(Aplausos)